welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link and i'm
rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we're gonna be talking
about
our concert experiences okay this is
pretty fresh yeah because
one of the ways it's so fresh that i
have been sort of
experiencing
the
yeah i know the pain
is not over you know yeah but
in the way that it has affected us so
much and keeping us from our normal
social interaction our normal social
social situations the way i kind of have
broken the seal on that is through
concerts
yeah that's a i mean that's a big one
when you find yourself in a in a
really large group of people
and especially when okay now none of
them are wearing masks
you know it's like all right this is uh
how does the big moment how did it did
you find yourself um
what was the first concert it was a free
of the first one you went to
well
uh we went to that outdoor concert uh
the lord huron concert that was a lot
less that was last year i think that was
the it was outdoors
yeah
and there weren't seats it was so you
were you kind of had your own little
zone
i mean
went to the john mayer show at the forum
and then you went the next night he was
there for three nights i went to the
third he went the third night um
i don't know if i went
to any no i went to uh
the uh a dead and company show which was
also outdoors
so uh yeah britain took me to one of
those
but before that i think before the john
mayer concert we went to uh a clippers
basketball game i think the clippers
game
you call them basketball games of
concert now no i'm just saying it's like
a sport concerto well there was like a
performance of the national anthem but
i'm saying that that for me was the
first i'm in an enclosed space with a
lot of people and that was basically
that was right after uh la lifted the
indoor mask mandate and so and and
pretty much i would say 95 of people
were like thank god
i'm not wearing my mask inside there
were still a few people but most people
were like let's just get on with this i
was definitely on team let's just get on
with this i'm not wearing my mask inside
this place i'm happy to be in here with
all these seeing all these smiling faces
right i mean i we watched
the national championship
and i was talking to christy about it
and she was i was like look at look at
all those people and nobody's wearing
masks and then they cut to a shot of roy
williams i was like damn roy is the only
one wearing a mask the whole place no
roy williams has been wearing that same
mask that very like decorative like
caroline it's like you know yeah he's
he's been wearing it the whole time well
you know what okay good for him i was
like okay but yeah concerts have
definitely
been a symbolic threshold that i've
crossed
um to say
i'm i'm getting back into i'm getting
back into things like it's social on a
whole new level and so going back to
concerts i found myself
having a new perspective
on a concert experience something that i
did not appreciate
before the pandemic
um so it's
yeah because
i mean i'm so into music
but i've never really been a concert
person
like i would when it comes to listening
to music
i don't like listening to
concert albums like i've never gotten
that live albums i did not do it i like
the studio process i like the refining
and the
perfectionism even when it's like
intentionally
even if you record it live and it's
that's kind of the
the approach that they took in whatever
album it is okay this is a band you can
tell that they're doing this this live
it's still
um presented you know it's it's still
groomed and and and manicured and
and it's not as intended and there's
people
who will say
you don't really get so and so artists
until you see them live
and i've just never been one of those
people even though we can talk about all
the concert experiences we have
i do feel like i'm turning over an a new
leaf
in terms of really appreciating the
communal experience of being at a
concert
everybody's there
for
the same reason or there might be a
couple of reasons people are there but
they're all positive they're all
celebratory and and it at least somebody
lost a bet
well yeah there may be some people are
there because they lost a bet that would
suck
i've never gone to a concert in any
given concert
one person there who lost a bet
and there's definitely people who are
like i'm only here because
my friend didn't want to come by
themselves but i don't even know who
this artist is kind of a thing yeah but
by and large you've got this group of
people that are into this artist and
with the type of artist that we are both
into
it's a very pot it's not like an angsty
experience no in fact i was noticing so
in
the course of two weeks i went to the
john mayer show at the forum and then
the bahamas show
uh which it was at some i can't remember
the theater it's a cool theater in
downtown but much smaller venue yeah and
i was just noticing this is essentially
the same crowd because well even that
shirt you're wearing the bahamas shirt
and it's like got that 80s yeah he's
kind of doing like the john mayer or
sobrock kind of
thing he does it's much more funk
focused but it's still sort of like
middle-aged white dude with electric
guitar like playing and kind of being in
the groove i would call it more groovy
than funk but yeah yeah so but one of
the things
that i noticed because
i i like to sit down at concerts
let me just right right and i'll get
into that for for a couple of reasons
but i was just noticing that even at the
most intense moments of a john mayer
concert and the most intense moments of
a bahamas concert it's still a bunch of
people kind of going like this
just kind of nodding their heads
moving their head just a little bit
there might be some person who's like
really there was a guy right next to us
in the balcony
at the bahamas concert so we got into
the balcony so we could sit down at like
a table i was literally sitting at a
table and i was like this is how i want
all concerts to be me at a table with my
family and somebody in a waitress oh you
had a way coming up and asking what you
want to eat i like that speed man
especially for that kind of show where
it's like we did that at the casey
musgrave show too at the greek there's a
little section where you can sit at a
table and somebody will come and get
your food orders like yeah you may know
the great gifts
i haven't seen that movie but it's a
great venue right there
in los fellas like just a few blocks
from where we first lived in some of my
favorite concerts outdoor amphitheater
that's a great spot perfect venue you
know at this point i'm such on this
concert wave that i'm like
maybe i'll just i'll buy like
whatever the season pass to the greek is
there's a lot of good people i think
this is a good idea because yeah i've
noticed
it's a great night out
it's for for our family we love to go
and i think this is true for you we love
to go as a family because we tend to all
like the same music like loch went to
john mayer all three nights with
different sets of people and last night
it happened to be me and shepard right
and then all four of us went to bed to
the dead and company twice uh
at least twice maybe three times yes
because they would that was that was
last halloween and he he this is what he
does he goes with a different
group of friends or a person each time
he goes and he's okay a lot of times
he's drawing somebody in like he's kid
kids
18 year old kids don't like john mayer
you know what i'm saying some do but
yeah so he's like bringing his friends
to john mayer and they're like i've
never really even listened to anything
that this guy does this is this is old
man music and then like but hey it's
pretty good because when you see
somebody in concert and you're like i
didn't know i could play the guitar like
that like that's pretty impressive and
it's so different you're doing the thing
once you you got to see him live to
really get well i think one of the
things and i and i and we talked about
this in a previous episode about the
resurgence of the garage band that's
what we called it right now we talked
about it in a
um
in a carpool
okay on the this because of the society
to hear that those are covered
we call it but it's like a 20-minute
version of your business
our prediction about the research every
month the resurgence of uh garage bands
almost as a rebellion to the idea of
someone just kind of standing on a stage
with a track going which
which it can be incredible and i respect
and i am into on some level but i don't
go to those kinds of concerts i don't go
to hip hop concerts typically and you do
i went to um well first of all yeah as
we as a family all five of us because
lily came home early came back from
college early she started her spring
break
a week early with so many classes still
being online she was able to justify
coming home a week earlier and it just
so happened she could come to john
mayer's show so like as a family we were
all into that so it is cool for i agree
for us to go as a family and
um we had a great time but i went with
lincoln and
three of his friends
to the trippy red show different vibe
uh yeah it was at the um
youtube theater which is like attached
to the sofi stadium
which is in the same parking lot as the
forum so it's like all in the same place
this is like a a smaller a medium-sized
indoor venue
and uh yeah we were wearing masks at
that point
and it felt a little weird
but
that was a i'd never been to a hip-hop
show and that was i mean the opening
acts were kind of a joke just people
jumping around and not singing
their own lyrics right while the backing
track just kind of and other people on
stage kind of helped them out yeah but
i mean
trippy red definitely commanded the
stage and it was just him
i mean there was no dj on stage there
was nothing else just a bunch of fog
and like a constant drone of an 808 that
like in between every single song just
keeps going it would
this
the dj who was like in the wings
would just hit this
this like low drone that shook your your
all your organs
for until the next song started and so
sometimes he will trippy red would like
walk around stage or like
take his shoes off
he would just be like
doing nothing on stage and people were
going nuts
and it was just like
like a cup one note just like a constant
it's like an earthquake yeah that kind
of clean every single song penetrates
your soul yeah that so there was never a
point where my ears got a rest and i'm
like should i should i have brought ear
plugs possibly they make those ones uh
that you can wear that you can still
talk to people i have a pair i've never
worn them to a concert because the
concerts i go to are they're not needed
oh yeah you you put them in
i should have brought those christie has
some she has this
because of her uh concussion it like
brings everything down to
an
acceptable decibel level
but yet you can have a conversation with
the person next to you it's magic here's
the hot tip that i i can't remember who
told us this but
if if you don't take anything else from
this episode of your biscuits you can
remember this if you're in like a super
loud space yeah if you're in front of a
speaker at a concert and you want to
talk to the person beside you and
they're like yelling at the top of their
lungs in your face like getting that
spit all over your face and in your ear
right in your ear and yelling right in
your ear and yelling that's what most
people which which can really damage
your hearing even more all you got to do
i wish i knew who told us this trick you
just take your finger don't put it in
your ear take that little flap
that little flap in front on the front
side of your ear hole and push that in
there and then just lean in and
someone and then you can tell the person
hey
talk to me at a normal volume you don't
have to yell you have to get close to
your ear you got to get close to the ear
like you're whispering just talk in a
normal volume and it's like
it's like a miracle yeah it's it somehow
cuts through the frequencies or
something i don't know how it works but
you have to get everyone in your group
to agree to this in fact and i suggest a
training session before everybody goes
into a concert so we're going into a
very loud place dad mode activated and
this this is how we're all going to
we're going to speak to each other as if
we're hearing something in an earpiece
because if you don't tell them
and they start yelling in your ear and
you cover your ear it's like well first
of all they do get hit oh he doesn't
want me to yell in his ear but also
maybe he doesn't want to hear me because
he's stopping you i gotta preamp this
actually helps me hear you put this over
put your finger over your ear and speak
in a normal voice
okay uh
there's there's there's a couple of
things that i've developed that i've
realized that now that i'm going i'm
going to concerts as an adult there's
there's a few things that have kind of
changed and things that i'm embracing in
my middle age but we'll talk about that
in a second and some things i want to i
i want to go back and talk about like
i i've written down some concert
memories yeah and a lot of them we were
both there for so i'll see if you can
remember some of these things there's
some there's some pivotal experiences
that we had
at concerts
and it sounds like
we're about to be concert daddy's
emphasis on the daddy hey you just see
us at the greek you know or be there
with your finger
dad
whoa whoa whoa whoa where are you going
hey you just why are you lowering your
seat right
i can do it like this one no because
it's just i can do it with my
no hands with it that's what i did
okay okay that's enough hydraulic
but speaking of concerts uh we went to a
brooks and dunn concert back in the day
and i'm gonna tell that story
but
yeah brooks and don is that that was
making the segway into this yeah that's
what i went into this yeah you're
talking about this album that we
recorded yeah yet another reason to be a
member a third degree member of the
mythical society every year for the past
few years part of our quarterly
collectibles one of them has been a
vinyl an exclusive vinyl and we love to
just adopt or you know find some music
that we love and then do our spin on it
this is brooks and dunn in the year 3
000.
you heard that right yeah we took
two our favorite books and done song
neon moon and then everyone's uh most
popular uh
uh brooks and ton song boot scoot and
boogie
and we created them as if they were
being made for the first time in the
year 3000.
you had the first time well i mean it's
like if we covered them in the year
three covered them in the year 3000 or
there was just another group that was
inspired by them i mean i don't know we
haven't really established the the
backstory but the music is supposed to
sound like it was in the year 3000 but
it they are authentic covers of these
two songs
yeah this is a fun project you got to
join third degree of the mythical
society to get this um exclusive
collectible join third degree monthly by
the end of april
2022 that's this month in order to get
this thing neon moon boost scoot and
boogie in the
future how we do it you gotta be facing
it's on the back pretty pretty excited
about that very excited about it it's a
collectible item um so one of the things
that has changed for me
i was never a buy the t-shirt guy
but i have become a buy the t-shirt guy
and wear it look at you you're wearing
it and you know i'm wearing it
as a as a visual aid um this is the
obviously the bahamas concert one what
did you realize cause i've had some
some thoughts about this too
well two things what happened two things
kids
right okay so kids happen a while back
but
you wanna you you know you're the dad
and you want to get your kids something
to remember the concert by yeah
um
this this is going to sound weird to you
but one of the things that has actually
changed for me is the way that i am
viewing t-shirts in general on two
levels stay with me here
okay
one is
very recently but also very rapidly
my relationship with t-shirt fit has
changed and it's really just a response
to the changing styles meaning that
if you go back
if you go back like eight nine years and
you look at good mythical morning and
you look at some of the stuff we shot
like our t-shirts were so freaking tight
i mean you had some that were so tight
they were painted on and i was right
behind you not quite as tight but like
we were wearing some tight t-shirts
right yeah it made me feel secure i was
wearing a medium
as a a short sleeve medium and you were
wearing a short sleeve
oh yeah yes
and then we transitioned to
you were wearing a medium and i was
wearing a large like if we were wearing
our own merch i was wearing a large
and then in the past
few months
i've just like quickly gone back to an
xl which is
it's really a response to
the styles changing right so the effect
that that had on me being able to
buy a t-shirt at a venue is like i can
just pick the xl and it's gonna it's
gonna be a little bit bigger but like
when you're wearing a shirt that hasn't
forget tightly yeah yeah there's no
forgiveness the fit has to work really
well it has to be long enough for me but
i'm just like i'm gonna get the xl so i
just walk up and i pick the design i
want and i'm just say xl and i just walk
out with it you always wanted to get a
shirt but you never felt eligible i
don't like t-shirts like i don't like
going to a site on the internet and
picking t-shirts that have designs that
i like it's i don't know why it's kind
of stressful
and i just i don't wear that kind of
t-shirt very often
but i like buying t-shirts that are
connected to
things that have happened yeah so like
if link lock and i are on a road trip
and we stop at a restaurant they have a
t-shirt i'm gonna get that t-shirt cause
it's like a memory from that place right
and obviously concerts are the perfect
opportunity it's a good souvenir so i've
changed my whole relationship with them
so now if we go to a concert even if i'm
just going to concert with jessie
i'm probably going to get a t-shirt
xl the one in the corner xl
and
if you see somebody on the street who
went to the show and they see your shirt
they pretty much know
that you were at the show because
they'll sell
they don't usually sell that merch
online you can only get it at the show
so right you know so it's this insider
type thing that that
yeah i've also got to have the tour
exclusive stuff
yeah um i'm feeling that so that that's
a big change in my life is hey buying
t-shirts with stuff on them i mean i'm
embracing that but to be buying concert
t-shirts
the thing about buying tickets is that
they're still really expensive i mean
especially if you're taking your whole
family that's the thing that i'm still
getting over and then
realizing where like there's all the
like getting used to the mad rush of
getting a good ticket when they first
you know are released yeah making sure
you you can like master the art of
securing a ticket in the right spot
because i like
more of a balcony
where i can
well i've never been down on the floor
like i don't think i'm ready for that
now i know for you and your tallness and
stuff there's but for me
i'm just
i like to have the option to sit down
and i don't
want to be forced to stand the whole
time i mean if it's a smaller venue and
there's like
j there's no seats down there in like
the pit it's like that makes me
i don't know that's a bit that's a lot
to be down there in that i'm not i'm not
to that point yet i think i would vote
but from a very like i'm saying
all of my adult life and definitely
since high school
ever any type of crowd it doesn't matter
what's happening but concerts apply they
fall under the the umbrella of a crowd
and people watching something
being six seven
every single decision that you make
about placement and posture is is is
filtered through being that big of a
person and now being that big of a
person with this much hair as well oh
wow they can't even look over your
shoulder so
i
am so conscious about this and it like
it actually can ruin an experience for
me if i get a bad seat and i'm in a
place where every oh everybody's
standing up now i've got to stand up
so what happened
obviously what i'm saying is that if i
stand up whoever's behind me and usually
two rows behind me and like three people
wide they can't see anything
and it and i don't like being that guy
right
so at the bahamas con at the john mayer
concert at the forum of course there's
the standing room down on the floor and
then there's actually they were seats
but they all stood up the whole thing
they all stood up to all the time but
then there's the balcony and we were on
the second row i wanted to get first row
but we got it was a it was a
you know last minute decision so we got
second row and i was like dang it
because if you got first row you could
stay seated
regardless of what happens right so we
get there
and then
john comes out
immediately two girls in front of us
stand up
and so i hear the woman behind me he was
very vocal said a lot of funny things
about john mayer and how sexy he was and
what was happening to her body every
time he picked up a new guitar oh really
yeah she would be like
john mayer
[ __ ] me
really yeah stuff like that not asking
him to do that just just like it's
you are strange sexy like is saying that
stuff she was with a dude
just like her husband i mean just like
verbally processing her sexual
frustration oh no now you've got the
green guitar oh
timer
yeah she's really in a giant area
they picked up that dobro like thing
that was she lost it she lost it yeah
yeah her water broke
yeah well some things happened
so but she says this is the first thing
i heard out of her mouth the whole night
she says oh no we're not standing up
that's as soon as these girls because
this is a bunch of middle-aged people
and there's some like 20-year-old girls
stand up oh no we're not standing no not
standing up give me a break how can you
be that into somebody but then not want
to stand up for him well because the
reverberation of the stand i was on team
not i wasn't gonna stand up i didn't
stand up so
okay i was that guy but i made my son do
it we definitely stood up well here's
what i said we were a little further
back than you nope they were the only
people that stood up and then there was
a resistance to st to sitting up to
standing up oh
and then i leaned over to lock and i
said lock
tap on that girl's shoulder and and ask
her if you can sit down
really yeah i was like i'm just gonna
try it i'm like you're gonna get no
you're gonna get him to try it i'm gonna
get him to try it yeah because like an
18 year old kid asking is different than
a dad asking right yeah and so and he
was fine with it because he was feeling
the vibes and what people were saying
behind us and he taps on her shoulder
she turns around and i see i guess i
couldn't hear what he said
but she like looks at him and shakes her
head and she keeps standing up and i
said what did she say she said no
i was like okay all right i i
i'm on team
keep standing okay so let me tell you
what i did the whole concert
it's tough it is tough they stayed
standing i stayed seated the entire
concert until the last song
yeah cause you're different because i
was like
and so i kind of like you're so much
taller shepard got a little bit shafted
because he was more blocked by them and
so shepherd which shepard and lot would
stand up quite a bit they stood up the
whole time and then shepherd and lot
would stand up when everybody else stood
up and i would never stand up because
i'm almost standing up anyway right
when i'm seated and then i would kind of
lean around these girls and kind of i
could see
half of the band
whole one whole one whole half of the
stage didn't see it the whole night
until the end oh no and then i could see
the screens the screens are great in the
forum well so i i guess
i can't do it maybe i'll backtrack a
little bit do what that girl was doing
to me to 15 people behind me they bought
a premium seat
for sitting down right
switch seats with me for god's sake i'll
sit on the front row and sit down it's
no different to you
yeah i don't i don't know why
i mean i know why they were standing
because they're really into it and
that's how they get into it it's like
saying it's i guess in their minds it's
like going to a party and saying hey
don't don't dance at this party or don't
listen to this music if you're going to
have a good time if you're going to a
john mayer concert and you and want to
stand get stan get the floor seats
that's all i'm saying well they're
forcing i mean they're expensive but i
think that if
getting the seat
that needs to be a s is for people who
want to sit
i i think that's the that's the
complicating factor i sensitive to the
fact that people want to stand up and
enjoy a concert and kind of dance and
whatever but
you know
our my guess my choices as a six seven
person become
the back row of the top which i'm not
going to do because i'm not going to sit
there
or the back row of the bottom and it's
like that's
did jessie stand up
because she's short her she wasn't she
wasn't at john mayer it was just me and
the boys okay
but did shepherd stand up so that he
could see yeah
yeah and lock stood up but he you know
he's still blocked a little bit but and
then the woman the vocal woman behind
you did she stand up
very reluctantly a couple of times
she'll be like oh no we're standing up
that's what she would say the same woman
that was just losing her [ __ ] john
mayer's sexy that doesn't add up to me
unless there's some sort of condition or
like reason that she can't stay standing
no but i think it's just because it's
just like hey i'm enjoying this and i'm
and i'm here and i'm in the moment
i used to be that way and now i'm like
you know what
stand up get your body moving like
really engage in it like i was i was
dancing man i was moving all over the
place i know your type i i there's like
i'd see like one out of i was loving one
out of like 40 people at a concert is
your type it's like that guy is either
on drugs or
just a certain type of personality i was
i wasn't like
moving like i was in another drug
universe there's a guy next to me at the
bahamas conference i've seen that
who he literally he and his uh partner
another dimension they had had a table
with the waitress and everything
i was like there's no need to stand up
brother but he was just i mean he was
like it was like you might you feel like
you might get hit by him if you were
close to him like i was glad that i was
like two two seats away from him it was
like he was trying to shed his own skin
like a snake and i was just like man
like you're also with me here and it's
you're making it a lot about you and i'm
trying to focus on this and it's like
somebody is like directing traffic in an
alternate universe right next to me well
i mean dead and company you see it all
i mean they're you know it
it's multi-generational which is
interesting so is john mayer uh
multi-generational but like it's also
multi-us
like
substance
like
crazy those people have a great excuse
yeah but i just don't i mean
i
it is fun to like give yourself over to
like you know dancing but
you are an exception because you know
that you're
inconveniencing
people you're blocking so many people
there are so you have to get that front
row seat if i go to a concert and
everyone is standing or if i'm like in a
lawn situation
no where people are standing i just i'll
i just stand up and i'm like some people
are going to deal with this and it's not
your fault people know it's not your
fault
you're that tall but i did see on like
the reddit forums
because i was looking at what people
were saying about the john mayer show
afterwards
you know the the the most hardcore fans
are the ones that are you know they give
them the hardest time about like picking
apart the set list and
this night was better than that night
and all that stuff but then people also
posting this was my view and it was just
a tall person in front of them yeah
that's like very well could have been
you if you stood so you did the right
thing stan cd you took one for the team
those girls in front of you didn't do
that
i i don't yeah i i can't come down on
one side or another yeah i think it's
their right to stand every time not
yours in a space like that i feel like
there's got to be a different way to
design
spaces i mean what if you just stood up
but you know in a lot of the photos that
we take together you'll stand up and
then you'll just spread your feet apart
yeah but that's problematic too because
you've got people and you're it's very
small it's your family so your family is
basically standing in front of your
thighs as you're like spreading
for two hours
yeah i can't do it as an air chair for
that long not an air
a spread is different than an air chair
i mean and but if i'm standing up i am
moving like i i don't i'm not like my
there there's like if i was inside of a
cylinder
you know i don't know how big that
cylinder would be there's there's
movement that happens within that
cylinder but like my hands and stuff
don't escape oh my hand yeah okay yeah
when it comes to dancing yeah i i i
agree with the cylinder it's kind of
like
you like the the beam me up pod on star
trek you got to stay within the inside
thing that's your space yeah i mean this
whole i mean listen i mean i i don't
even want to get into them by my
collarbone into the mosh pit thing i
keep my pit my my my fist by my pits you
know yeah
i've seen that move
because it's like you wouldn't be into
it
no point in my life
at no point in my life was i ever into
the idea of like
getting the arm in the face
you know like unexpected like i don't i
don't understand the appeal well i'll
i'll tell my
experience with that so this was
senior year in high school it had to be
so
kurt cobain had passed away and then
dave grohl started the foo fighters and
then they released their album so this
is you know
this was probably i guess it was like 96
and um
maybe 97
and
they had a show at the i think it was
the ritz
in raleigh and
the let's see i wasn't dating
yeah it was pretty early in senior year
because i wasn't dating my girlf my my
girlfriend
who was my girlfriend for senior year
freshman year in college but like this
the other girl
that i another girl that i would take
home
from school i took candace home from
school
and
uh
she was a sophomore she was the same age
as
the girl that i was interested in who
would later become my girlfriend
and then
so i and so i was talking to her about
the show and like the foo fighters have
a show and she was like i want to go i
was like okay let's let's go to this
show and we were just friends
i don't know if she was interested in me
but she also knew that i was interested
in her friend and then whenever we
decided to go which is a strange thing
looking back on it like the two of us
were going to go to this show but very
early on i was like
i want to invite
so and so and maybe we had started
dating or maybe we were about to start
dating but this was very early on
and so it was like then this
it was basically candace's idea to go to
this show but then it was my idea to
bring i'll just say she was my
girlfriend i can't remember the
do you remember her name i can't it was
i can't remember the the uh the
chronology of it but it was basically
like first second or third date
i was like oh i want to bring her so it
was the three of us who went and it was
even though it was candace's idea she
became the third wheel yeah and we go to
the show and we go so early
and there's no seats in this place it's
one of those like black box theaters and
you cram in
like literally everybody crammed in i
don't remember there being an opening
act
um
but it was i mean this is like
on the you know dave grohl foo fighters
on the heels of
nirvana's no more this is all we've got
this is the new version of nirvana
um so we will show up
and people just started packing in
packing and packing in and we were about
four people back from the front of the
stage
and just general admission yeah and we
waited there for
probably an hour and a half waiting for
the show to start
and more people kept showing up and they
they kept packing us forward
and it was like we started getting
smushed smoosh mushed
and
it started getting hot i i
hate this feeling and it was the type of
thing where it was so tight that
you couldn't you were shoulder to
shoulder chest to back everywhere
and
they started like the security guards
after an hour of this they started
handing out water bottles sometimes they
would just fling the water on everybody
it was like it felt post-apocalyptic
and then they would hand water bottles
and people would be guzzling water
bottles
just like
just dying of thirst
and you would just hand it around i was
drinking water out of water bottles
after somebody else drank half the
the bottle i didn't survive i didn't
even know who they were like for me to
do that you know we were desperate but
it was the 90s
and then it was before germs and then
they yeah and then they foo fighters
came out and they started playing and
then there was another press forward
from like way in the back like everybody
wanted to get to the front but there was
no way to do that and we were smushed so
close
it was you couldn't breathe and then uh
i looked over there and uh
candace
just all of a sudden just
i was looking at her and all of a sudden
boop she dropped she was gone this is
just dangerous man and we and since we
were so close to the front
you know we and some other people like
waved
said hey we need some help and we like
picked her up and like she was she
wasn't unconscious but she was like very
woozy and like not with it and
we put her over
the barricade and gave her to a security
guy
who then
took her away
and there she goes the third wheel i'm
like well yeah
she gets home no more third wheel i'm
just here and i was like
i mean
that was so
i'm so embarrassed but what about we did
not follow her what are the ethical
like
it was just like she was gone before you
knew it if a third wheel of a date drops
and it is being taken care of by
protecting parents by professionals can
you just move on i mean i i don't i
don't know if you should feel better was
i supposed to jump over the barricade if
this person is a designated third wheel
in the third wheel
by definition if you're riding a bicycle
and the third wheel falls off you can
keep riding
that's why they're called
it's unnecessary
you know what i'm saying it's not that
if you think
is taken care of
you can keep right i mean and you did
you shouldn't feel bad i'm sorry candace
i'm sorry for what what we did uh
but you know i didn't mind being pressed
against my new girlfriend that wasn't
like that was nice it's like you know
it's like okay it's like we we're kind
of skipping the holding hands thing
entirely because i'm every part of my
body is pressed up against the back of
your you have to make a choice though
because if you're side by side you're
both pressing against strangers so you i
got behind behind yeah i got behind her
what'd you get in front of her
no because i tried that once i got
behind her there was no getting in front
once you were in a scene oh yeah you
were like you were locked in yeah yeah
and um yeah so i was kind of protecting
her from the crush right
i just think it happened so quickly i
was i wasn't making
i you know my brain wasn't fully formed
right yeah until 26. and i was
dehydrated
and i'm not proud of it she ended up
being okay
you know but how long how uh much later
did you convene i believe it was after
the show
so the entire show she was kind of
like where was she she was she recovered
and then she was kind of in the back
that we didn't have cell phones right um
that's why they could just throw water
all over the crowd no phones to worry
about
i mean
my girlfriend was her friend so it was
just as much on her it was over here we
were just bewildered
to know what to do i hate that that was
scary it was never been the closest i've
ever been to to that circumstance
was actually when
um state beat florida state and we all
rushed the field
uh oh yeah you could chuck amato's like
first year
and
everybody was getting up on the goal
post to bring it down and i was in this
crowd and i was like and first of all as
a tall guy you actually have an
advantage here like you don't feel like
you're you can see over everybody's head
but even then
i was like i just feel like i could fall
and get trampled
and then the goal post whoever was on
the goal post the lots of people it
comes down wow and this is back when
they didn't make the breakaway goal
posts you know this is before they
started making the ones that they just
claps at the end of the games or
whatever like you can't bring them down
this giant goal post comes down
and literally is coming down i've moved
my i'm locked into position but i move
my head out of the way and it bounces
off my chest and it falls on the ground
yeah that's crazy it was like and then
they do we just thought then i just pick
it up and we start carrying it to
hillsborough street
and
but wow i felt so
i wasn't there vulnerable in that and so
i've never if i sense that happening and
i don't the thing is
go to the types of shows where that is a
phenomenon
because i'm a middle-aged dad
so
and like lot goes to hip-hop shows but
he just goes with his friends and i'm
like you just
trippy read there was an open mosh pit
area and people were trying to mosh but
they weren't good enough at it and there
wasn't quite enough people to form a
tight enough space
to to then create
these mosh pockets
and the foo fighters it was so tight
that people were trying to much but it
wouldn't happen there was some crowd
surfing and then at the very end they
went into this whole like 10 minute
feedback driven start to destroy their
equipment thing which was pretty amazing
to be a part of
years in a couple of years later i saw
311 at the same place it wasn't quite as
crazy i actually saw no doubt i was
there for no doubt okay we saw the no
doubt show the back
that was that was that was like tragic
kingdom album like their first album
they were like huge still playing clubs
don't speak all that you know all of
those spider webs all
um that was that was a fun show
um
but
i guess yeah when my girlfriend
we left we made it out candace was okay
hopefully she didn't tell her parents
about how much of an a-hole i was but
i think the companion story to that is
the concert at campbell university
campbell university would have these
like christian bands come into d rich
auditorium and we would just show up
and and and go to some of these shows
yeah and a little bit later as wax paper
dogs we would perform at like one of the
one of those one of the fest one of the
christian music festivals that was like
smaller time
but i remember there was a group of
people up there watching i think it was
third day
yeah third day came to
um
and
i don't know i was in i was in the back
and i was chewing gum and my girlfriend
was there and she was somewhere and but
we weren't together at this point and i
was kind of in the back maybe you were
there do you remember this concert i was
in the third day concert okay we were
there we were probably hanging out in
the back we're like you could be in a
seat you could sit down you weren't up
front where there was like a lot of
people
pressing together
and
i just i don't know why i did this again
i guess i was an [ __ ] i didn't
realize this was the third day concert
where you did this
i was
i was done with my gum
and
instead of putting it behind my ear
swallowing it or you know what putting
it in a receptacle or just continuing to
chew it or just chew it until you see a
trash can i took it out of my mouth
and
uh
i have the gum in my hand and then i
just i don't know i didn't really think
about things
i wa i don't think that i had a there
was no it wasn't an active decision
besides just being an [ __ ] i guess
and i took the gum
and i just threw it
towards the front into the crowd
i threw it into the crowd i don't know
again it's like i'm
i i have no defense for this like
i was
i don't know it was just like a teenager
like that's as bad as i got like oh i'm
so bad look at me i'm throwing my gum at
a bunch of christians
and i'm also a christian so hey we're in
this together and then
a few minutes later
uh or a while later
um i did find my girlfriend and we were
hanging out and she was go she said
you want you wouldn't believe what
happened
[Music]
like somebody threw gum in my hair
i know all the people up there in the
crowd
i threw the gum in my own girlfriend's
hair
and i did not tell her that i did you
never told her i'm pretty sure i didn't
man
you never at any point in your
relationship this is one of those
stories that i've i told you you've told
this story so many years ago six years
ago and you i wonder if at that point i
remembered more and more
but my recollection is that i never told
her that i threw that gum in her hair
because
if i'm an [ __ ] enough to throw gum
i'm also an [ __ ] enough to not own up
to it when it lands in my girlfriend's
hair did you
was it currently in her hair or was she
like i got it out i've been that's what
i've been doing for the past 20 minutes
you know what i don't remember
i don't remember that i found some
peanut butter
at the convenience stand it might
i'd like to think that it wasn't in so
deeply that it didn't work it wasn't
like a toddler
it was like oh gosh then yeah and she
pulled it out of like the five strands
of hair on like the surface of her hair
whose gum is this
i apologize to her too i don't know it's
like so
concerts brought out the worst the thing
is is that by telling her it probably
would have made her feel better in one
sense because this is like when you're
grossed out by somebody's gum and their
saliva to be oh that's my boyfriend's
saliva i'm going to get some of that
later
why did you do that that's not a big
deal who am i dating nobody
i definitely had had to have a sense
that like this could make or break a
relationship like talk about showing
your true colors then you have to
explain yourself and there's no
explanation so
that makes me think about the we
definitely went through
just because of the culture that we were
in we went to christian music concerts
and christian music sort of festivals
and stuff now we always had this
we set in judgment over christian music
even when we were in a christian band
because we had taste
yeah yeah we thought that by and large
it was not it was like two-bit rip-off
it was whatever was popular
and with like cringy jesus lyrics i
remember
so once we started the wax paper dogs
and we started getting we were heavily
influenced by 311 once we started trying
to write our own music right we were
bleaching our hair we were wearing the
big g the most worthy of influences and
writing i was writing riffs on the
guitar that i thought were
approximations of 311. yeah
they were
very distant approximations of 311
and but we were having a hell of a time
we were really and so we would go to
these places and we went to one
place uh
not to play
but as fans because tooth and nail
records was a thing remember that tooth
and nail neck records may still be a
thing but
that was they had like alternative bands
mxpx that were pretty um
they were more legitimate mxpx was a
punk band that was kind of like
are they christian are they not well no
fx was like a very
well-known
punk band that then
okay so then it's okay let's do our
christian version of that mxpx
like we we also had a little bit of like
a judgmental eye towards tooth and nail
bands because
the way that we would do our music is
it was pretty explicit i mean musically
it was all over the place lyrically it
was also all over the place but it was
pretty explicitly christian and then we
would do invitations at our concerts
just to i know we talked about this
before but just to remind you
that's when at the end of your cu your
concert
you start getting very serious and the
music gets very serious and then link in
this case who was the lead singer
would begin to sp
and just you know you know this man
and just think about giving like 17 year
old link meal the one that was throwing
gum in his girlfriend's hair the
responsibility of speaking saving
us about jesus and god and the plan of
salvation and then offering an
opportunity for people to make a
decision for christ in the moment i so
wish we had videotape of this oh my gosh
um
but that's how we did our concerts right
so i don't know why we we looked down
our nose at mxp because they they were
they were legitimately talented we
looked down our nose at them not
musically we looked down our nose at
them a little bit
in like maybe side eye to be like these
guys like legit christians or they list
kind of like california christians yeah
like i mean how christian are these guys
so what do you remember about the show i
remember going to the mxpx show
and there was other bands that were
playing
surprisingly not a lot of people there
no
and then i just remember going to the
bathroom okay yeah that's what i
remember and the lead singer was pissing
at a urinal
and so were we and so we did two
do you remember saying something to him
while he was pissing
uh
because i don't think i would have done
that
i've had people do that to me many times
but i probably did yeah
it's like i don't know what i said amen
love your love your music
something something nice how's your
wiener something something
interesting and an insincere compliment
yeah that's all i remember about that
the tooth and nail of it all i do
remember going to carowinds for the
christian music day
and audio adrenaline
was headlining that festival
and
i remember being really into the music
that day because you're kind of like in
this youth group setting but yeah they
were good it was pouring down rain no
but i haven't but it was covered
the the venue at carowinds was largely
covered so we got under that part i
remember already being soaked
but don't you remember that song big big
house yeah with lots and lots of room a
big big table with lots and lots of
views a big big yard where we can play
football a big big house it's my
father's house here's a song about
heaven
that seems like it's for preschoolers
but here's the thing
i i feel like i can stand up for them a
little bit because you go back and
listen to the song
it is like the cheesiest song you can
imagine and you can't imagine any
teenagers ever being into it however
so much of 90s music was like that yeah
even non-christian stuff musically they
they they had chops
the lyrics in 90s music
were the very few exceptions was just so
like just but we wrote this on the back
of back of a nap but we did three
seconds we didn't listen to
christian music we listened to
secular music we listened to 311 we
tried to like we're going to we're going
to emulate them but we're going to do
this legitimately
in in christian band circle but i
remember going to freshman year in
college
incubus
they were releasing their second album
and i discovered them the year before
and we started emulating them in the
band and this was kind of weird because
that we were sort of
peaking in our christian not peaking but
we were getting to a very high level of
sincere christian commitment
in that every area of our lives was
affected by our our sort of commitment
to jesus oh yeah so but i was a huge fan
of incubus i knew that which literally
means the demon that comes and screws
you when you're sleeping right yeah but
the um you know i knew that that the man
this picture of the guy from the 70s on
the cover of their albums was the lead
singer brandon's dad like i had done
like my internet research that's the
only reason i used the internet was to
look at bands websites i was like man
they're coming
they're coming to mission valley really
small venue
and then
i went there we watched the show
uh this is brandon still had dreads at
the time you went to the show with me
but then i was like
i'm to hang out i want to i want to meet
him
i want to i want to talk to him and so
i waited a while i remember this i
waited for a long time
and then actually
maybe i went early because i remember it
being daylight it hadn't been daylight
it had been early so i go early and i'm
like hanging around and then i see him
walking around and he's there's a
laundromat on the other side of the
venue and he's going to do his laundry
from like the tour bus and i like meet
brandon and i start talking to him
and i talked to him for a long time and
my
my goal
was
to
talk about jesus of course i wanted i
wanted to save the lead singer of
incubus's soul yeah of course because i
was such a huge fan how wholesome is
that does that make up for me being an
[ __ ]
no actually that is sort of very
holistic
but i was but i cared about him so much
and i liked him so much
but
i wanted to i knew that the only reason
way i could connect with him is if he
thought i was cool so like i didn't ever
really talk about jesus
i got this friend man i asked him a long
hair and a beard i asked him about his
spiritual beliefs and he was very nice
and he talked to me for
i like you know it could have been an
hour man i remember you telling me about
this conversation because i was not
present for i went to the concert but i
didn't go to the conversation yeah yeah
yeah it was awkward man it was like i
would have been shorter if i'd have been
there hey we got somewhere to be
i think i got his email address
you've still got the lead singer of
incubuses email
yeah address yeah maybe use it i mean i
need to dig up my hotmail account are
they still an active band yeah yeah yeah
i mean they got much bigger after that
with their like third or fourth hour
well speaking of bands dads just a
little sidebar here
uh post malone's dad
had uh tweeted
you know i like he was like
um
here's a little something to brighten
your day and it was our gmm episode oh
really
yeah so he's like i just love the fact
that he's his dad tweets yeah yeah like
yeah he's you know he doesn't have that
many followers but like he's very proud
of his boy
and uh i gotta look at that uh but i i
was thinking about um
going even well
the first concert i remember is with
my dad taking me to beach boys at walnut
creek so walnut creek ended up being
kind i think he kind of changed our
lives in a lot of ways right because
they built one up venue outdoor
amphitheater
big bands had an excuse to come to
raleigh in a way that maybe they weren't
coming before i don't know maybe they
were just going to dorton arena in
fayetteville there wasn't a place for
people to play music that i remember
unless it was like carter finley stadium
like huge oh yeah so but yeah dortmund
arena like back in the 70s and it's in
in raleigh had uh like led zeppelin you
know who else has played dortmund arena
we have ren link and merle haggard who
we saw twice
the uh
the beach boys were playing and of
course you were young
i was in seventh or eighth grade oh i
went with my dad
and john stamos was the drummer
i don't know if you remember
uncle jesse i don't know how long he he
did that gig
but he would be he would drum for the
beach boys it's kind of like john mayer
playing like being the lead of dead co
but not really anything close to that
but right so
you thought it was awesome though i
thought this was this is kokomo days
cause like full house was still
happening
no it wasn't
in seven in 19 okay when did full house
had just gone off the air 19 maybe a run
1990
1990 i don't know man they play kokomo
of course they did yeah that was i mean
that was a big thing i just remember so
the cool thing about walnut creek
is the lawn you know i never i actually
don't remember ever sitting in the seats
it was always the lawn seats long
because you could get us you get a
ticket for like 30 dollars yeah and my
dad and i are on the lawn and there are
these two
uh increasingly drunk
middle-aged ladies next to us
and and then i don't remember exactly
how it happened but my dad and i just
end up slow dancing with both of them
what
are you serious yeah not like not like
like just sort of just like having a
good time you know
like and not for that many songs
but it just was something that just
happened and and
it was they were and you never spoke of
it again
it was just like hey we're just dianne
hear about this of course she did it
wasn't like it wasn't a scandalous thing
it was just like a kind of a fun thing
it was kind of like the community square
dance where everybody can dance together
and yeah yeah and you're gonna go back
you're gonna ride your own saddle back
home and it didn't get it didn't get you
know it never turned
sexual even
on any level it was just very much just
like but this is a little bit i don't
know
a seventh and eighth grader
well what do you mean
yeah but i wasn't thinking about
middle-aged ladies at that point you
weren't
okay i'm talking these ladies were in
their 50s oh okay all right i mean
i remember something wrong with that now
i'm 44. the first concert
about when i was right first concert
team i remember
going to
was
my mom took me and you to see me see
hammer at the dean
yeah man and
that was huge i was such a i mean this
was like
can't touch this
so he is such a huge
moment in pop
music and you know i was a huge empty
hammer fan you were you liked him but
like i i
completely drunk the kool-aid something
about yeah because i didn't understand
how much of a
how not good his music was compared to
all the rest of the hip-hop that was
being made oh yeah because we were just
a little southern white boy that didn't
really understand it yeah we were
you know we were 13 years old yeah
um
and it i mean
everybody loved m.c hammer he was he was
a pop icon he wasn't a hip-hop icon yeah
it was a different thing and yeah like
the hip-hop community was going was
everybody that was coming they were
rapping about him and making fun of him
and i was like
well just another point of reference to
kind of bring this into complete clarity
vanilla ice was touring with him yes so
i i mean there's i there weren't many
hip-hop artists who were going to let
vanilla ice cream in vogue vanilla ice
did not show up that night we found out
when we got there and i was so upset
yeah well i think we were more excited
about vanilla ice to be honest with you
at that time yeah i mean just think
about this in vogue
yeah
vanilla ice and mc hammer it's a big
night
and then and my mom and your mom was
there
my mom and my mom
was into it she was loving it
but vanilla ice didn't show up but in
vogue really brought it
what a man what a man what a mighty good
man
i remember
i don't feeling things i don't remember
a lot about the show but it was huge it
was like a big stage production it was
like the biggest thing i've ever seen
many years later you and i went and saw
the stone temple pilots at the dean
smith center
um as like sophomores in college
and that was a that's that show i
remember that show sounding really good
yeah that music sounded like great in
that video for it to be four guys
just like
playing i mean like they were
it was really impressive not just that
four guys and one of them is just
singing
yeah i mean like the the one guitar the
guitarist in that band
doing
a show like that yeah it's it's crazy
impressive the uh yeah the um the
guitars and basses are brothers like the
leo brothers or something so like
they were uh
yeah they brought it man i was i was
that's the first time i went to a show
and i was like paying attention to the
sound like this actually sounded good
and i remember our friend josh wanted to
go but for some reason we we didn't
invite him i don't know sorry josh it
was a little bit of an [ __ ] was it
the brooks and dunn concert at walnut
creek
um
so we we saw a number of acts at walnut
creek including van halen which we
weren't even fans of just that wasn't
our idea we saw george strait there and
we all got in the
joey smith drove his dad's suburban and
there was like
nine of us in the suburban and we were
in the very back and we were we were we
were going to george strait so we were
like cowboyed up
we might have been wearing cowboy hats
maybe definitely cowboy shirts and we
were um
doing dip in the back and in the back of
a suburban now i got you so
sick
yeah you got to wait to get the concert
to dip but was that the which concert
was it that somebody had tequila
that was it it was brooks and dunn so
there was this huge
tailgating thing happening in the
parking lot
and
i we were just you know we were
we were 16 17 years old and
i'd never we've never been to like
parties where people are like
drinking
liquor and just raising hell you know
and it's like so we're walking around
and i'm talking to people
like like these these rednecks at the
tailgate turning up tequila bottles and
i'm like what's up guys brooks and dove
you know it's like this is my i'm like
you would think that i was drunk when i
i hadn't had a drink
um
and then once you start being friendly
with these people they're like hey man
you want some you want to you want a
shot of tequila
and i'm like oh you called my bluff i'm
like nah
yeah and then uh i don't remember how it
happened but it was like but i'll eat
the worm yeah right i think i think that
was my response it's like i'll eat a
worm bro i'm not i'm not gonna i'm not a
prude you're calling my yeah you're
calling my bluff i'm not actually going
to drink but i will eat the worm because
and he was like all right and he got
that boy to worm he got the worm out of
the bottom of the tequila bottle and uh
i ate it
when the first time you've eaten worms
anus yeah it was the second and it
definitely wouldn't be the last who knew
that i'd make an entire career out you
didn't eat the worm no i actually don't
believe that i was present for that
moment
uh because i remember hearing about it
and feeling uneasy about it
you know because that was that was in
that moment where our friends were
beginning to kind of party and we were
still a member of the group and like
kind of like what you're saying
we never had prudish personalities like
if you talked to us and you hung out
with us you wouldn't be like these guys
are super straight edge i had a raised
hell personality it's only when you but
like a
fundamentalist
mentality yeah once
in terms of what we actually did and
didn't do a conservative
christian when i heard that you drank
when you ate the tequila worm i was
there was a part of me was like
is that drinking i mean
i mean there's some there is some
tequila in that you know there was
definitely this vibe of like what is
link gonna do if i'm not around yeah
like i feel like i gotta be there to
keep him from falling yeah
uh but it just always starts with the
tequila with a worm you know yeah i i
first was the worm
not not typically it did not taste good
i mean
it probably tasted better than if it
wasn't soaked in tequila for a few
months or however however long that
happened i think we saw travis tritt
there
at walnut creek um i went to travis
street with my dad actually
i have seen travis tritt in concert i
mean i have to assume that it was one it
was pretty good i remember i remember we
went into the brooks and dunn show and
that's where i bought the license plate
that i put on the front of my truck and
i bought it as a joke i just want to go
on record and say
buying a license plate says brooks and
dunn
was a joke it was irony and putting it
on the front of my truck but it was also
like
not at the same time not
that we
lived like that in a lot in a lot of
ways and they had a karaoke booth out
there where like all the tents were um
where you could like get your food and
your your merch and stuff they had a
karaoke booth
and i went up there
and i
we both didn't you sing too
i sang um big city by merle haggard and
i remember people would people stopped
and started watching me sing it because
oh here's this 16 year old singing merle
haggard i like this guy and i and i and
it really fed into this redneck
mentality i just don't have a room i
don't remember it was it was fun to be a
part of
that was it and i was a huge brooklyn
dunn fan
uh the most the most memorable
the most memorable uh
concert experience though i i think has
to be
sort of the moral the string of merle
haggard experiences
starting uh 16
when we we go to down to cm
uh at the alabama theater in myrtle
beach myrtle beach
and then i had to miss a soccer game is
that that's this that's the night when
we followed the tour bus yeah i was a
starter on the soccer team and we drove
my my nissan pickup probably with the
brooks and dunn license plate on the
front all the way down there to myrtle
beach to watch the show and then we were
just gonna drive back i think cause i
don't think we got a hotel room no of
course not um but he was driving south
after the show
and
um
these stories the kind of the string of
merle haggard's stories are all told in
detail in the book of mythicality
in one of the chapters talking about
being a fan that's right because it kind
of came full circle that we we followed
him as a kid we saw him multiple times
including in dorden arena
and then
always the youngest guys in the crowd
yeah it was these two teenage dudes who
were
not with their dads three decades yeah
you know like there were some kids who
were there with like grandparents or
whatever dads but not us we were just
there completely sincerely into this
thing
and then
of course as an adult having the
opportunity
to
meet him backstage
in that weird i'm not going to tell the
whole story we've told the story in
detail on good mythical morning and in
the in the book of mythicality yeah but
then and then finally
meeting him and at a point where he
could see him getting on the tour bus
uh with him and going to the back of the
tour bus and having him kind of sit
there with a towel around his neck
um clearly you know a
70 something year old man
exhausted from playing another night and
these two
super fans coming back there and just
like not knowing what to say and being
that moment we're just like
we followed you
we followed when we were kids we
followed you
across the state line and it's just so
cool to get to meet you and you've been
so you know you just don't know what to
say to somebody who's been that
influential right and he was just kind
of like you could kind of see it on his
eyes i've heard this a million times
right
all right look you got something for me
to sign
yeah yeah i'll sign this i'll sign your
albums
yeah we got the albums uh hanging up in
our
in our office right there that he signed
he misspelled your name but then he
corrected he corrected it that was that
was good
so i mean it's easy to do i'm glad that
we're back on the concert train and you
know it's it's it's about creating an
experience like bringing people with you
and then having experience with all the
other people that you don't know
it's not but i think you know it's also
not
all
all fun and games when you got people
not wanting to sit down and people not
wanting to stand up
you know it ain't easy there's lots of
there's lots of things that can happen
and i always forget the worms to be
eaten i always forget about that element
of
you're preparing yourself for this night
and then you're like oh well
because the worst is when you're next to
somebody who's just
super drunk yeah super drunk and super
spilling beer on you uh and then you're
just like oh man i can't
i'm not going to be able to enjoy this
it's like going to a movie theater and
it's in a movie theater if somebody's
being loud next to you you can just tell
them to shut up right in a concert i'm
not going to be the person you don't i'm
not going to start a concert fight
that's why you invite more people and
then you sit in the middle of all okay
yeah that's just that's how you do it
yeah yeah
it might be a good idea to get that
um
to greet i don't know about getting a
season pass as much as i i'm just
thinking like between the hollywood bowl
yeah and the greek theater all the
venues downtown where the smaller bands
come
basically that's a great thing about
being in l.a you you could be you know
everybody's going to come every weekend
almost every night of the year you could
probably go and see somebody that you
have some level of familiarity with yeah
including paul mccartney
uh he's coming to sofi we should go see
him i mean uh but the reason why i
brought that up is because that's my i'm
gonna give my wreck
i gotta stay in the music zone another
music documentary i watched on a plane
coming back home
mccartney 321
is a
mini-series three episodes
uh on hulu it's um it's just rick rubin
and paul mccartney
at rick rubin's i think is it rick ruins
studio but they're in like a couple it's
very intimate like the cameras are
really far back and zoomed in and like
they're just having this like very off
the cuff
conversation
uh rick has his uh
if you don't know who rick rubin is
that's that's uh
i'd love to meet rick rubin i think i
got to put him on the list like that
would be freaking awesome to meet him
uh legendary producer
he has his like
mixing table sound board whatever you
call it out there and then he's playing
beatles tracks and some wings tracks and
just getting and then paul is just
talking about and they're they're
adjusting the levels
and talking about it and so like to
illustrate a point
that like isolate the vocals so he had
like the stems for all of these
um
beetles and wing songs and it's like
it's it they're not too long and it's i
mean it's the opposite of like the get
back thing if that's inaccessible to you
but you're like a more of a casual
beatles fan like paul talks about how he
teaches people to play the piano
in in one of them uh so each one is kind
of themed in a different way
and it's just it's very loose
and uh like he teaches people who are
gonna be playing like with him no like
if he was teaching a kid how to play
piano
like a beginner
yeah i was like i mean my kids can play
piano but i still thought about sending
it to
to lily who
yeah when we were talking about garage
bands you know she's in a band right she
just went back to school and i was like
you getting together with your band you
guys are playing
um it's like do you guys want to play
in places and she's like no it's just
for the fun of it we might be putting
together like a cover set list and maybe
maybe something will happen but it's
like it makes me so happy that she's in
a that she's in a band but uh 321
mccartney on hulu well it's called
mccartney321 check it out
and we will speak with you next week
i'll be telling you all about uh my
recent
road trip from maine to miami for real
man i've been waiting to hear about it
you can't tell me yet so
next week your biscuits hashtag your
biscuits
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms thanks for being your
mythical best
[Music]